paying for college can be a daunting
Endeavor but there is help out there for
students and parents here to tell us
more about ways to get financial aid for
school is financial expert Elaine Rubin
thanks so much for joining us thank you
so much for having me yeah this is one
that a lot of parents lose sleep over
how do we pay for the kids to college
so this is something I had to figure out
with my family through my college
journey I was a first generation college
student so we had to go through the
forms figure out the timing figure out
the deadlines and honestly it just felt
like I never quite knew if I was doing
it correct so this is kind of what I do
now is trying to help people find their
path in their journey and find ways to
help pay for it and they're out there
you say there are plenty of options out
there my very first tip is always to
start a budget so even if you don't have
all the information yet you may not have
your college cost quite yet this is a
great time to start having conversations
with anyone helping you in your college
journey to figure out how much money you
actually have to put towards your
education yeah and to look at your
different options so creating a budget
will start creating that Baseline it'll
help you later when you're actually
going to school so that you don't over
borrow and you aren't spending so much
money that you run out of financial aid
and other things that you've already
received so it's always the great first
step yeah you don't want to come out of
college already in major death no you
really don't yeah I've become more
familiar with this as my fourth kid is
heading off to college FAFSA you know
filling that out is important the FAFSA
is the most important financial aid
application out there it's the free
application for federal student aid and
that's the first application that you
want to look into because that's federal
grants Federal loans and federal work
study so that is the most important
application but there could be a few
more you just want to double check your
College's financial aid website to see
if they require things like the CSS
profile or if they require any
additional applications for scholarship
programs that they're aware of and they
recommend you submitting the forms and
some people may think they are not
eligible for certain financial aid but
you discover you might be that is one of
the top myths out there people think my
family makes too much money I'm not
going to qualify for anything even
though there are some federal programs
that are need based there are a lot of
programs out there that are not the
FAFSA actually is also an application
for state and institutional grit and
other types of funds which might have
different thresholds and you know that
FAFSA application can be one of those
words that people kind of cringe at when
you hear it so advisors offers a FAFSA
guide that we update every year that'll
walk you through the process yeah it's a
little complicated and that that's very
helpful and you do want to make sure
that you know there are deadlines to
some of these so that is one of the
biggest tricks and one of the biggest
tips out there know your deadlines FAFSA
has state school and federal deadlines
the most important deadline will always
be the one that comes first and you
don't want to submit late especially for
programs that could be first come first
serve and that could be a lot of states
have first come first serve policy so
you want to track those and get those
together to submit on time great
information Elaine thank you so much for
being here today thank you for